Heiko Maas virtue de Mayo's and you did
Rihanna mini grappa myself
we haven't traveled to Libya as expected
due to the security situation there they
think that it's a good endeavor good
result a good opportunity for the four
ministers to express our strong support
with Berlin process and to assess our
worrying about the situation in Libya we
are calling for an immediate stop to any
further escalation of violence and also
to the external interference which has
been increasing on the last days as you
know Libya is a priority for the
European Union and we will be actively
engaged with all relevant actors in our
efforts to stop the hostilities and
achieve the resumption of a political
dialogue we know that the situation is
worsening day by day and the only
solution to Libya once again we have to
repeat has to be a political negotiation
among the parts there is no military
solution but worried as we are by the
situation in Libya and in Iran we have
called for an extraordinary Foreign
Affairs Council a scheduled for this
Friday